any of you girls would you would you
mind if your man cry to you came to
party cry yeah I wouldn't mind I had my
partner of like nine years cry I'll be
like yes my babies
yes my baby needs meat for your partner
of nine years
I've had I've been with someone for nine
years okay so I have a question um
you're not with him anymore no I'm not
who broke up with who I also I broke up
with him he should have cried every time
I know it's I know it's like every girl
that it's again it's not you yeah it's
basically proven no no I'm just
anecdotal no stuff I've had girl after
girl come on my podcast and everyone
that says their boyfriend cried to them
I have a second question who broke up
with you it's always them but it always
depends on what wait he didn't cry in a
way of like he was actually being
emotional I was telling him listen I
don't know what you're doing right now I
gave him some facts but the situation
happens and I presented him facts and I
was like this is what's going on as your
business and he the only way he knew how
to communicate was to break down
at this point if I can do is you know
cry when you broke up with him is that
what it no no no no this was before I
broke up with him due to the fact that I
just feel like where you're trying to go
and where I'm going on two different
angles now before was on the same train
you jumped off and hang out the window
like we didn't like you're doing your
own thing but he cried based on him
trying to be emotional and be kind of be
like f not kind of thing and he couldn't
control his emotions so he's you know
what I'm saying and how long after did
you record no it was yes I would say
that he cried within the first year or
two of us being together and we spent
another four years if not five together
did you get it but he was doing up other
things so
that's that's the reason I know I just
don't think it's a coincidence but it
depends on how you cry though that's
what I'm trying to say all right but I
think a lot of times like women we don't
know what we want because it's like it's
kind of like how many times can a guy
cry till you like you know you didn't
cry that something
at some point no yeah we'll give you one
yeah
wait wait but if you wait come on that's
cap if he's crying every day you're
leaving
different and so you know at some level
like you're going to leave at some point
no for me I thought if a guy cries it
shows me that you have a level or
Consciousness consciousness of emotion
and I can't be with someone that's
heartless just cold ruthless man you'll
just be like I don't cry just what is
that I think it's still human
would you guys feel if your boss started
crying has that ever happened to you
female boss male boss yeah
yeah nope no yeah I I didn't feel sorry
for you
been spending too much people damn
business in this place and yeah what
goes around comes around and I looked at
you uh threw you a very small napkin
because I wanted to see you fold it up
and let you be no no that's not what
we're about to do victim nope I've never
I've never seen it I've just heard
that's like a phenomenon like I've just
heard like girls yeah yeah yeah yeah I
feel my managers break down I feel like
we get emotionally like what's what
overwhelmed women get overwhelmed
whereas men get angry I feel like men
cry from a part of their body they're
not used to hitting you know what I mean
that makes you come from a popular body
they've never hit before like no one's
ever hit you there so like what feeling
is this
no men can cry like men men back out
inside
before your body creates those tears
you're bugging up internally trying to
understand what
and he's crying then that's in
expressing an emotion but like if he's
crying because you won't let him hit it
then he's a cuisine
it's kind of it's kind of like how many
times can he cry like I mean I think
women I think at some point you get one
a year yeah
that's a lie no but you know what life
is hot no but perfect no for the first
time you've been honest for the first
time we've got a woman that said exactly
what you can do you can get one a year
it's like what tends to happen is we
won't say you can give you one every
other year
it depends on the topic like it's like
if if he like if he's going through it
like yeah a lot and like he's like going
through that emotion and if he's crying
I don't I think vulnerability can be
attractive in a way then if he doesn't
fix his problems then he's still crying
that's what I was going to ask I'm gonna
ask you so if he's crying like he's like
oh the first time he's going through
that he's crying every month to um
February's crying Wednesdays um you know
what I mean at the same time
I've offered him counselors
go ahead well I was just gonna say yeah
like obviously if they're crying a lot
over like something small like Tracy was
being horrible to me at work fair enough
you know it's like ridiculous like all
right I'm done with this but in reality
if it's a traumatic experience someone's
going through or like something's
happening and it's a constant and
sometimes their reaction is to cry I
don't think that it's a sign of weakness
some sometimes vulnerability is strength
every question I have a question so
let's say he he has whatever the
situation is how how long can he cry
about it so he cries Monday can he cry
Tuesday well can you cry Wednesday yeah
honestly yeah if it's something like
it's like if you're just crying about it
and if you can do something to change it
it's like yeah no let's say he's
depressed yeah Monday how how many days
in a row can you cry well this is the
thing that I think if it was anybody if
they were relying on me and they were
constantly crying to me for something
that they're going through internally I
am happy to be someone's shoulder to cry
on however if however you are
constantly crying and it's like they
yeah it's just
it's like we can do these things to help
you this is a different way of going
through it it's just
if it's only crying nothing's happening
then it can be difficult on the other
person who's having to help them support
them so objection
listen
where's the camera
okay
this is for men
a loss in your family loved one friends
cool
a movie that hit you deep and your eyes
water okay
that's it
that's a lot of pressure listen listen
this is real life yeah you have to be
a rock
he must you must don't ever ever
or do you respect would you respect your
lovely girl we spoke before men do not
listen to that and okay listen to me
yeah in a second one second one second
one second this is for the men I'm gonna
hand it back I'm not gonna talk too much
this is for the men real talk I'm not
trying to make people laugh
life is real you most of you know that
already you know the struggles you know
what's going on you know what you gotta
do you don't have that time you can't be
doing that stay focused stay on your
purpose a loss cool
a sad movie that hit you somewhere cool
get back on job
that's it so I'm gonna just as a man let
me just add on to another man said so
yeah guys like this is to the men out
there
um do not cry to you don't cry well
because women as they find it very hard
to explain to you what it's okay to cry
about so the best thing to do is not to
cry so she said you can cry once a year
Pearl said once every two years and she
basically said you can cry for about
three or four days but by the fifth day
if you're still crying out I'm not too
sure so this is a lot of mixed signals
for men so the best thing to do is like
what Alex says is just to be a rock and
I I'll be honest with you I ain't gonna
cry no movies because because no no and
but he can give that to you family I
pray that we don't have to go through
that stuff but at that point you know
men can show emotion but I just think
it's a lot safer for men
just don't cry bro I think I say
something
um I I personally think as a man if you
go to a woman
you're crying me I'll lose respect for
you it depends what you're crying about
like
um if it's a loss or something really
bad like of someone dying then yeah but
as a man I feel like it takes you off of
your purpose when you spend too much
time crying about things that you're
just wasting time and energy and I think
men really value respect and if my man's
crying often I'm gonna lose respect for
him I don't feel like that's a real man
I don't cry to me about it all the time
that's but that goes towards both
genders realistically don't sit and cry
about everything all the time
women women cry all the time over
everything yeah that's all you're doing
for it
other than the gym and the Pumas where
are you gonna let this that's how I was
gonna say
wait wait wait wait man can men can talk
to other men yeah
and Mendel and men don't really care if
they're girls crying over stupid [ __ ]
like they're kind of used to it we cry
over dumb [ __ ] like yeah we're dumb [ __ ]
all the time can men tell me where the
outlet is this is what I struggle as
somebody as I personally I'm a little
bit hesitant with men when it comes to
outlet like
um I just I just think it's other men
like I think men should go to other men
I think like women try to be mad that's
you and your woman mind which I
appreciate is a beautiful
where is a man going to I'm going to go
in the gym where's Alex going Alex Alex
gonna go to me and this is what and then
and then this is what's gonna happen and
then if I don't feel like I can speak to
Alex I want to speak to blessing the
blessing don't feel like he can speak to
um to me he's gonna speak to Devante
that the idea of this is we're not
supposed to speak to every single man
quiet to every single man but if if my
if Alex comes in Christ to me I know
this is a very serious situation because
he's never cried and men don't cried at
that so I won't look at it like how you
look at it I'll look at this at my boys
got to a a level where he's crying to me
now we need to figure out what's going
on we need to come to a resolution so
crying to women
I will not lose respect for him in
actual fact I'm gonna gain so much more
respect for him because I know he's
showing me emotion he's never saw what
we've gotten from you guys is that he
can cry but he he has to know when to
cry and he and he can't cry too much and
if he cries too much he needs to so
that's too many slack caveats right
you're right I just gotta be able to cry
to you and you can't tell me what I can
cry about and how long I cry about if
you tell me I can be emotional to you
you don't get to tell me what I can be
emotional about this is why I just say
just don't cry bro Alex and cry to me
talking talking sorry just quickly so so
just talking about um early we're
talking about leadership and 50 50 and
bosses and this that and the other if
you're if you're a man and you cry
over you know not a loss or what I said
before
um to your partner
you've demonstrated
the the inability to be stable you've
demonstrated that you can't be trusted
you've demonstrated that you can't be a
leader you can't be followed because if
I'm if if you're be if you're being
followed and then it gets Peak and then
you're depressed or whatever the
situation is and you're crying
we don't see presidents crying like you
don't see leadership you don't see the
CEO of a company crying well unless it's
a woman but it doesn't mean she doesn't
because he doesn't because you don't see
it doesn't mean they're not crying no
you're right but that's what I'm saying
they don't do it in front of the people
they're Leading Men are saying wait wait
Matt wait men are supposed to lead women
so you don't you don't see the CEO going
to a company meeting and start crying
it's the same thing with like if you're
if you know I know some people do the 50
50 thing but if you want to be in a more
traditional relationship where you
follow the man you're with then he
shouldn't go to the people the person
he's leading and cry of course not I
wouldn't agree 100 understand your point
but I feel like she was saying like
you're allowed to be vulnerable
You're human until it's time for you to
pick yourself up like I feel like in a
relationship depending on yours and
guys's you know boundaries obviously
like if you follow more traditional
methods and etc etc like you're allowed
to be vulnerable if your partner says
that's okay with you you can be
vulnerable for that time being and then
pick yourself up like it's cool yeah but
the whole point is wait the whole point
is that each girl is different and so
it's kind of like rolling the dice like
look at this from a guy's perspective
you know me I said every two years she
said you know you could do it three days
four days whatever whatever it is
everybody but wait but every girl is
different and so it's like for one girl
you know she might be okay with it this
long for another girl she might be okay
with it this long so it's like why risk
it even the ghosts that say it's okay
that sounds nice that sounds nice and
it's very emotionally intelligent and
it's beautiful though the girls don't
even know that they've lost something
for you
the attraction yeah they get the ick
whatever that thing is that made them
feel comfortable in your leadership or
your presence or your even partnership
whatever whatever that thing is they've
lost it they don't they didn't they
didn't even know it happened men
focused on your purpose
shoelace with a bunny ear bunny ear over
like a baby doesn't it and I'm just like
ick he's never coming near me so now you
see the problem we have right so like
it's it's it's it's
but why would he risk that like why why
wouldn't he just say you know what in
general I'm gonna try not to cry in
front of her if it happens it happens
but in general unless it's super serious
I'm just I'm not gonna generally we all
have that rule like I don't walk into a
room expecting to be upset and cry I
just think if it happens it happens it's
just like you know if someone pees
themself you don't make a big deal
you're like go off of there
consume you realistically and that's
where communication comes in again you
can literally discuss this before you go
through it but the problem is women
don't know what they want I know exactly
but a woman that does and a woman that's
got her you know priority straight can
communicate that with a man and
obviously if that's not the case then
that's not the case as many of you know
I was just banned on tick tock and we
are demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible